today on how to be a man these aren't
even my kids these are kids that I liked
on the street that I took pictures of
strap in and get ready for a non-stop
pro ride of man's floats of proportions
this is tqez how to be a man Jim
Gaffigan is one of the highest-grossing
comedians in the country and he does it
all from this New York City apartment
here's Jim Gaffigan with how to be a
boss JG Jim Gaffigan in the house
comedic legend I'm friends of them
what's up
it's Jason I'm here for them I'm here
for the GQ shoot oh yeah yeah your
business here you're a boss who are you
a boss other thing is to be a force is
really important all right say I go I go
to subway there's different people
there's people that pull out the bread
there's someone that slides it into
their bar back I'm their boss and how I
treat them is gonna inform how they
respond okay so you're saying when you
go through the line and you're like I'll
have pickles
I'll have onions right I wouldn't get
onions but yeah I'll have pickles I'll
have tomatoes I wouldn't get tomatoes
therefore I'll have whatever you're
gonna have our own teammates
peperoncinis you're saying in that
moment directing someone to do your
sandwich managing that's management okay
and then that's common sometimes if I'm
ordering two sandwiches for yourself
yeah you get two for yourself well you
know it's like say you want one for
later you want water and you want a
meatball sub right because you want the
you know fish's got protein and then
meatball is good
here's where the command center this is
this is your office it's a command
center there's you know there's a lot of
work going on in here so I don't want to
rob that okay there's no one in here way
to say your wife works for you yes she's
in the bedroom because so that we don't
get sick of her
okay and she she has meetings all the
time but like the FedEx guy Bonnie yeah
what's the status on the Rhode Island
gig I want you to walking down on my
iPad right now do I have everything I
need for the that gig okay great
just wanted to confirm that it's so hard
to find that level of service from you
guys want a snack or something how many
bowls of cereal live you guys since I've
been here uh I look fine so Jim you've
conquered it all you are a captain of
your industry huge business how's it
feel well why why you why you talking
like that
she's watching Walking Dead so I don't
it feels so good to be in control I
don't have anyone tell me what to do I
see something I decided whether I want
to do it yeah
I don't she's your wife Josh the shots
shut shop I ran I can't hear you I can't
push up a car just to canter Justin
can't get it Justin - some guys going
this is ridiculous what I can't
understand you
there's no one way to be a great boss
but one thing's for sure Jim Gaffigan
unorthodox approach to management being
successive opinion I don't know because
I need to get it done I need to get I
don't have a permit or a street for more
awesome videos that teach you how to be
a man subscribe to our YouTube channel
and follow us on Twitter